THE UNCHARTED ZONE.
( CHEERS AND APPLAUSE )
THE UNCHARTED ZONE IS A
PRODUCTION COMPANY IN CENTRAL
FLORIDA THAT SHOOTS MUSIC VIDEOS
FOR AMATEUR MUSICIANS.
THE ONLY PROBLEM WITH HIRING
THEM IS THAT THEY'RE APPARENTLY
WORKING WITH VIDEO EQUIPMENT
FROM THE MID- TO LATE 80s.
AND THE FOUNDER INTRODUCES ALL
THE VIDEOS AND HE LOOKS LIKE--
A PLUMP WHITE MORPHEUS THAT
DEFINITELY OWNS A WINDOWLESS
VAN. -- IS THAT FAIR TO SAY?
LET'S TAKE A LISTEN.
CAN I JUST TAKE THE BLUE PILL
AND GET THE ( BLEEP ) OUT OF
HERE.
COMEDIANS, I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU
A MUSIC VIDEO FROM THE UNCHARTED
ZONE AND YOU'RE GOING TO NAME
THE ALBUM THAT IT'S FROM.
FIRST ONE. THIS BIG FIVE
ASSISTANT MANAGER FROM BEYOND
THE STARS.
AL.
>> I GOTTA GO WITH DORK SIDE OF
THE MOON.
>> POINTS.
TOM, DO YOU HAVE ONE TO ADD?
>> THE REAL NAME IS ACTUALLY,
RUSS MAIN'S "DOES THIS EARTH
MAKE ME LOOK FAT?"
I'LL GIVE YOU POINTS. YOU
NARROWLY SCRAPED BY.
HOW ABOUT THESE MIDDLE-AGED
PARTY ANIMALS?
♪ SMILES OF LAUGHTER, YOU'RE
GIVING ME MY HAPPILY EVER AFTER
>> JESUS CHRIST, SHE NEVER GETS
A WORD IN.
REGGIE.
>> THE ULTRA-WHITE APBUM.
( LAUGHTER )
( APPLAUSE ).
>> POINTS.
TOM.
>> I JUST CALL THIS ALBUM WILK
AND DONNA-- LAST KNOWN
FOOTAGE OF DONNA.
>> LAST ONE.
THIS TROUBADOUR WHO WAS
APPARENTLY AT THE SEAL TEAM 6
RAID ON OSAMA BIN LADEN'S
COMPOUND AND NOT IN FRONT OF A
CRAPPY GREEN SCREEN AT ALL.
♪ YOU CHOSE YOUR ETERNITY
♪
>> YEAH, REGGIE?
>> SONGS IN THE KEY OF RACISM.
>> POINTS.
( APPLAUSE )
( LAUGHTER )
>> WEIRD AL-QAEDA YANKOVIC.
POINTS. DONE.